from epic plays comebacks and insane
crowd reaction there is no denying that
there's a lot of hype in tekken
tournaments
in support but just like in the other
event there are also some unexpected
things that can happen during or even
outside the matches
ready to go stuff like game glitches
funny player reactions pop-offs
[Applause]
these awkward moments can even get the
crowd going or sometimes get the
commentators a bit distracted
wow that was sick once again i'm drew
and welcome to the funniest moments in
tekken tournaments
[Music]
left on the clock now he's just gonna
take out oh my god
eliminated
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the throw whips that's punishable
oh man
wow
wow steve looks
irate just not happy about he's
tightening that stick up we talked about
it earlier
not over yet alley kick
second tim nice work
nice work
[Music]
good game good game
i can hear him huffing
not quite grabbing the headphones yet
not ready yet take your time oh let's
get the lure you look pissed
but oh your mic's not on
okay yeah so you look exceptionally more
mad than you normally would tell me why
oh no man no no tell me why i wanna i
wanna be i'm not playing how i want to
play one two well i thought you said the
the headphones didn't work or something
there's no sound on his side well that's
a good reason to be mad and also you
switched out your stick too yeah it was
uh
you got like four-sided
excuses
good games though you played well no i
dropped like multiple combos you did but
i mean so did he
yeah
man you look pissed i'm feeling a little
uncomfortable
[Laughter]
definitely need to play in these uh i
need to get these warm-ups before i'm
entering tournaments
this is not feeling good it's really bad
[Music]
cause you shouldn't have turned the mic
on and sat down if you were that mad i
can't help but i'm not i'm not worried
about that i definitely just want to be
able to play someone well look seven
more tournaments to go here's what it is
i'll run it back hopefully i'll let me
enter another one yeah they will
you're a legend around here man
tasty are you kidding me
[Music]
i believe it's takoyaki and it has
pink mayonnaise which is mint taiko and
then there's the little sushi called the
little
fishings on there it's from easy eggs by
jar these are eligible
anyway if you give me free stuff guys i
will show you out anytime on stream so
make sure if you're in singapore are you
coming at easy eggs by jar
it smells good i'm gonna eat it later
though
what is this thing this place called
eggs and things but it looks like taco
is this just an egg yeah why is it
called eggs easy eggs is it like an egg
oh
it's a quail egg or something all right
here is it you think i don't know a
fried quail you want to wait to find out
then
[Music]
so what is it
what do you think about that match
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
i don't know i don't know what that was
but
thank you
there's a fish egg in there there's like
a dog egg in there or something an egg a
donkey egg in there i don't know what
kind of egg that was but thank you
i guess i don't know how anything goes
in singapore man yeah of course
[Music]
damn he's getting way in there with that
blouse
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
come on let's keep it sophisticated will
ya
[Music]
that [ __ ] has a zipper on it
[Music]
what the
how is that
oh my god am i the only one that is
instantly thinking about
[Laughter]
what the hell
why don't you just hold a sign that says
put your hair
i cannot believe the [ __ ] that these
kids do these days
what the hell
is this
i've never
i've never seen something like that
[Music]
now this is going to be as classic as
you can get mishima versus mishima no
walls you used kazuya and devil gym oh
casual one of the characters he actually
has a pretty high rank with so i'm not
sure if you would even consider it but
kazuya i feel has a lot of tools that
can deal with devil jin see us yeah
we're going back to the same stage
i can't believe this happened again
we got through the summer
yeah something unexpected so
it's a brand new set and oh my god three
in a row
we are back in the infinite stage arctic
snowfall
oh my god
oh my god look at that the first match
goes to knees
oh yeah it's working out he has been in
control of the match you guys have seen
it i mean he has won
are you serious
kudans he doesn't know what to think
this is why this stage is banned when
you do bets
this is unprecedented how many times
this is four in a row now
what's going on
we can't get away from the russians
all right
it's cold in here yeah it's snowing
outside all of a sudden this has got
really cold there we go kudas of course
not happy with that from his reaction
what are the statistical odds of it
it's crazy we see the variety anyways we
are into it now so we are going to go to
the stage select and you know sage like
has been acting kind of crazy lately i
don't know if you watch the match
but we got that that
arctic snowfall stays like five times in
a row and i i've had nightmares i've
been dreaming about arctic snowfall at
least five nights in a row i hope it
doesn't happen oh my god did it you did
that commentator's curse you called it
all right production team take five
we're out there's uh there's a ghost in
the building that's definitely uh
[Music]
i wonder if they have someone like
dedicated for that like they go that's
awesome we got to do that at every
tournament hey
soundboard is just like the real steve
not a hard worker he's on break
damn steve soundboard also on break huh
yeah he water break not working hard
and just like the real deal he gets he
turns it on when i call him now all
right steve he's back is there is there
a sound board for for when he asked for
water what do you guys like to say
why do you guys keep saying sound board
he's here
yeah sure doesn't matter sam gonna take
it that's looking good look at charm
that was a good asset right there
it's quality baby
you know they got really good samples of
him saying that to you like you can hear
a smile
that was good here we go the match is
going underway
oh hi he's got another chance here that
hope kick
i love that too much did you press that
one which one last one
[Laughter]
oh steve
needs to commentate with himself oh my
god he just controls it by himself
what's the idea what's scared about it's
gonna affect his hair i know right he's
like come on bro he don't want the sun
roof on his head man he's gonna get a
tan of me like summer right there
yo get professor x out of here man it's
no x-men around
[Music]
[Laughter]
nice nice job though for both players
that's talents
[Music]
is a
multi-talented person it is that is ever
seen him flustered like this oh my god
again harada's finger definitely inside
john ding right
the punishment wow man rick's the stick
is sick yeah it's a good one
it's the hori h-wrap i don't remember
which one he's done some custom work
under the hood yeah he switched out the
ball tap it's got the first four buttons
yellow up there sound button sound will
stick oh my goodness look at that tall
drink of water at this point oh man
got a
prime seed
oh my
god
this is going to be a good topping for
jdcr
and i believe this is first of two all
the way up to top three
it's it's very rare to
find
it's very rare to find a situation where
jdcr is not in control and that's really
that's really i don't remember what i
was saying whatever who cares next game
thanks for watching and be sure to
subscribe too
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you